greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 20th the [ __ ] May where
the [ __ ] did the year go it's a
beautiful day to be alive
the church is brought to you by me
undies listen me undies me undies me
undies as a podcast fan you've heard me
and every other [ __ ] schmuck with the
microphone blab about bras boxes and
briefs for years but the one thing is me
undies is the softest and most
sustainable Underpants in the [ __ ]
world it's like having an angel crater
you're [ __ ] nuts all day every day I
wear me on these every [ __ ] day do
you understand me you guys saw me when I
took my nuts out and the comedy store
thing I [ __ ] had me undies on I love
them I don't give a [ __ ] what you think
alright it's time to get away from those
white undies and those [ __ ] John
Laflamme undies you're not that [ __ ]
dude me undies are [ __ ] made with
more dull I love them they comfortable
now I make an adult decision and get
yourself on a monthly plan for a clean
fresh and soft Skippy's what don't I do
for you [ __ ] I got your
manscape to shave your nuts I got you a
blue chew so you can [ __ ] get your
dick hard I love you [ __ ] pay
attention to me I'm grooming you
[ __ ] all right me undies is the
way to [ __ ] go and you get me undies
delivered straight to your door with
free shipping and they come in all
shapes and sizes from extra small to
four X or bodies or welcome even fat
[ __ ] like me they're even listen what
you do is if I'd say you're a fat [ __ ]
get a size smaller so they feel even
more comfortable running nuts they
control everything you live in like a
doctor you understand me
right now do me a favor go to me undies
me and these will not stop though every
one of you [ __ ] tries one pair
trust me when I'm telling you just try
them me undies has a great offer for the
church family for any first time
purchasing we're gonna give you 15% off
and free shipping listen to me this is
the way that y'all give it a try
give it a shot Columbus did you're
sitting there with those
otherwise your ass smells like ten dead
[ __ ] rats and you wonder why I can
[ __ ] stick my finger in my nutsack
right now fresh because it keeps the
moisture out of your nutsack you
understand me
even when I go to jujitsu I [ __ ] box
or workout I'm sweaty all hello my nuts
a nice and [ __ ] dry that's me undies
so do me a favor right now go to me
undies calm and put in Joey slash Joe
you go to me undies Dom I'm gonna get
you 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed alright go to me on these
dot-com slash Joey right now it's a
no-brainer get yours right now me and
these dot-com slash Jones
[Music]
welcome to church [ __ ]
Oh
it's that [ __ ] today it's Wednesday
the stimulus check still hasn't got I
told you who gives a [ __ ]
there's no debtors prison you're
slinging dick you're alive you're
breathing you got an apple it could be
worse it could be worried I saw the
[ __ ] cops tearing up the little
homeless Hut I'm the hunger did you see
them no beat up on two little skinny
homeless dudes with no masks on then
they won the white gold [ __ ] she liked
[ __ ] you talk to a homeless guy
you better have the whole suit on it's
like you're going to the moon you see
those people live under the tunnel you
go talk to them like I bring them to
sandwich I draw it out of him run like I
can't I can't
they got covert they got everything they
got [ __ ] that hasn't even I do I give
him food my dog I'm the nicest picked I
listen I pick certain homeless people
all right there's a little Mexican guy
in lancashire me walks around like he's
lost every time I see him I bang him out
with a 20 the black dude up by in-n-out
burger he's not a bad guy trying to bang
him out and then I got my personal
bodyguard [ __ ] Rambo to the black guy
the return of the black guy black planet
he's six for six what do you want to do
he finally got a haircut I don't know
got it
he gotta know how he cut it he cut
himself it looks but his head is he's
you know he's black dude nice-looking
dude but its afro square like he just
took like a [ __ ] thing with his head
looks like [ __ ] a kid and play like
one of those but he's looking good I
always do come with 21 I see him you got
to take care your local homeless people
forget these local little businesses
[ __ ] them they want to sell antique
chairs they wonder why they're going out
of business why are you torturing people
smart you're in no danger if you saw
them at the chairs you better get a
[ __ ] Korean to go in there start
filing nails or something music here in
know things every time I see a fire now
I think I think of Jewish lightning Oh
looking downtown the other
that's all you think about people a
burning [ __ ] up that's a bad fire
downtown
that was a hash whether the actual
actually hurt some of the firemen my
heart goes out to some of that and fight
like firemen got blown off the ladder
again that was a very bad fire the other
night so my heart goes out to you
[ __ ] still the toughest people
the frontline you know to all this [ __ ]
look away fine I'm number Doug Stanhope
after nine eleven bucks damn okay
funniest [ __ ] jokes going and the
joke went like this that it was tough
being like you know four years of you
and the marine you got your dick sucked
but after 9/11 it wasn't cool to be a
marine or a [ __ ] soldier it was cool
to be a [ __ ] new york city cop no it
was cool to be a fireman yeah so firemen
were getting their dicks up left and
right now it's cool to be a nurse like
your nurse again your [ __ ] eating
people are spanking in he asks it's cool
to be a [ __ ] nurse man like it's
amazing who rises from the [ __ ] ashes
after a disaster like now they're the
[ __ ] frontrunners now we we never
thought hard nurses worked and doctors
work bro I hate [ __ ] emergency rooms
I think that's the worst job to ever
sign up for
why because there's too much uncertainty
I don't have the heart to work in an
emergency room like I remember as a kid
going to emergency rooms and it just
being a bad situation like I haven't
been to those kids knock on wood I don't
want to talk about it no more sorry I
even brought it up okay let's talk about
what I've been looking at in lancashire
lately and now I see him in the [ __ ]
day it's amazing what happens when
people go starting when people need
money I'm not my laughing no money I
know people are [ __ ] living on it's
hard for people but it's really hard
when I first met Lee I used to hang out
I used to go to heart cafe was this
outlandish if I wasn't going through the
story yet I'm not a [ __ ] dummy but
there's things I'm not hip to like we
all like I could see a drug deal
playing a mile away yeah I saw one the
other day really yeah I was just because
I take weird rides you know like I take
weird rides and the I could spoil a drug
deal at CVS
they met at CVS oh [ __ ] so as I was
walking in like they were meaning like
he just got out of a car and they met at
CVS and do the drug deal which I did
something I would do
CVS is good spot there's a lot of
traffic there but you notice different
things you know like you you there's
things I'm not looking for so I don't
know I don't really notice it right when
I first moved to the valley
I will go lancashire midnight and it'd
be like after 9:30 which nothing is
going on in Lancashire now it's coming
to life they're building a Whole Foods
and they've got like a massage place
flexor rama like one of those chains
massage arama yeah they got Jimmy John's
and something else firewood Pizza and
across the street think I got a protein
thing and like a weird restaurant like
you're on keto it's starting to put a
life over their butts nine years ago it
was just a hot night two three block
yeah and then there was Starbucks on
Magnolia and then there was the Train
which is another block and a half and
the only thing on that corner is the
federal and yeah if you don't know what
I'm talking about if there's an episode
when uh when the black guy gets arrested
and Sons of Anarchy and they're bringing
around around the side there's a movie
theater so help portal theatre that went
down there but that's the only thing
that's on Lincoln guys was the ha and
the federal and I would sit there at
night I would call D'Agostino the guy
who was on the punch a few weeks ago
this got to be ten years ago and I got
the steno can I come down here oh yeah
come down to the last spot and I would
go there and I didn't want to sit in the
side so I would sit outside they had
tables I said we met yeah and I would
sit outside and go like every 15 minutes
a chick would walk by by herself a black
one
a white one a black one another black
one I never thought about they weren't
bad looking but you know I'm one now I'm
talking about the Agostino I'm talking
to Adam hunter you know I'm talking to
the comics at the time that are hanging
out there and one night I'm like you
know what man this is too [ __ ] crazy
these chicks are hookers Wow yeah and
then I met a girl yeah she asked you to
go the skinnies I said leave your single
boa and the next day you're like she
wanted 50 bucks so oh yeah sure yes you
weren't the like I supp she didn't know
she had a bandage on her head and he
even left black nobly she's getting out
what she just got hit in the head with
something was going on I don't want to
know nothing but you know whatever this
so for years they cleaned the
blankenship to have a movie Peter like
Emily's there so they really cleaned it
up I don't see nobody you don't see
[ __ ] nobody you come out here at
night six months ago you don't see
nobody the movie Peter has people going
in and out the Japanese people burnt
down the sushi place they Jewish life
and then got caught they burned half the
block down he's gonna check any really
oh yeah what's in the paper like two
weeks ago he's go to jail
oh they cut a deal something's going on
he's going to jail number one that
happened yeah and then Joe from the
coffee shop tried to beat him up with
the cops got there because he burnt down
the coffee shop the Jewish lightning
went south he went yeah listen that's
why Jew is a good they predict the wind
Jack's don't know what the wind that's
for Indians and [ __ ] Jewish people
leave it does do you know the downwind
is [ __ ] he lit the fire like up wings
and it went up the corner that burnt the
library a gym and the Joe's coffee
[ __ ] yeah he went the other way the fire
so my point is listen
you know mattify just called you they
know who they know somebody they got a
relative who knows somebody had a
lighter partner these are just jokes
my point is that so now we hit the
crisis right and things are bad again so
I take my little rides because my
daughter home schools from 10:00 to
12:00 so I don't want to be a nuisance
and have her know that she's in the
office so I leave them alone I take a
ride I come here I take out my notebooks
and I make my calls
who are gonna torture I said I go to the
weed store early and get the hell away
before all the Jeremy people go there I
try to do different [ __ ] things at
different times right and one night I
was fun [ __ ] ride like I was like you
know what it's I need to go for a ride
so I took one of my [ __ ] joints with
me and I went to go to a YMCA was the
night before they opened everything
right good I talked about that I won in
the end we're doing exercises and I
couldn't go in there so I parked in
front of Brett need you to place yeah
and the hooker
she made eye contact this one gets
better
like I just thought that was one night
oh no it don't stop there guess what I
saw today what a hooker Gelson's at
Johnson's blacker than the night I think
they get dropped off at gross because
what I used to live on support telling
you right down the corner from your
[ __ ] house oh [ __ ] he was right there
48 Wow
me and my wife could not [ __ ] believe
it searching for it was a no no she was
there looking at the Stars
yes she was looking for dick yeah she
was looking for dick on the way out of
the supermarket that's not the first
time I've seen a black chick at Gelson's
looking for dick and broad daylight but
we had remember we had that one that was
like the Walker like around like the
coffee shop a years ago she was like all
the one that survived I'm in my shoulder
one time we can't believe how hot she
was and she would wear blonde wigs Red
Wings she would make eye contact me but
they cleaned her up she disappeared
but now that they're back if you go to
in-n-out burger now if you drive up
towards it and Out Burger
yeah across the street those city hotels
they're outside they're standing outside
like and they don't stand in clusters
like they used to like want to go out
there for a little while you could see
it they've all hookers have always
intrigued me just that a woman would
stand on a corner and take a chance with
a guy in a car that's the ballsiest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard of in my
life
anybody can shake that it's on the
Internet big [ __ ] deal
haha let me see you get down to the
[ __ ] corner yeah and work a corner
and be known to be on that corner like
to be known to be on that corner like
people know that you're there at
midnight when they get out for you're
not there you'll be there in 30 minutes
and I wonder how I mean obviously you
hear horror stories but people do it for
years so it can't go better all the time
well I don't know I don't even I think
Vegas is legal and prostitute in Vegas
Nevada yeah prostitution is legal in
Nevada I never really saw it in my face
until the last time Joe took me to a UFC
and I left on a Friday night I didn't
wait for the fight I took that 6:00 a.m.
flight you gotta be at the airport at
5:00 and they were [ __ ] hookers
everywhere downstairs I was checking out
it was mind-boggling to me I didn't want
but if I see a hook they're working in
Vegas like even at the South Point when
I used to work the South Point alright
the South Point is really good they
clean up but one would slip in there
from time to time
oh yeah and while we we eat not the
seafood clam bar and the corner there I
would watch them well we'd have a table
I would see how they worked on them you
know what they're operon day is how they
see the guy then they sent two from the
guy and then they make an excuse to sit
next to the guy you know I'm saying and
then she gets up and then he gets up two
minutes later and they walk on separate
exits
it's interesting that you that you're so
interested by because I know you you you
are like a self-admitted prude almost
like it's weirdly like you're it's
nothing I'm a hooker guy but the art of
it as always it's not that I respected
listen whatever a woman wants to do with
our bodies they're all [ __ ] business
I applaud those girls couple weeks my
lord that girl Jamie write on my podcast
because she's broke she's not showing a
[ __ ] he's dancing with her titties or
whatever that takes a certain type of
balls you know there's no wait you're
saying it's like you get a waitressing
job right now it's not like you'd give
it off its job right now you can't get a
job as a secretary again you can't get a
job as a chef right now I'm not saying a
woman should be certain things but it's
even you know for a woman right now what
are you gonna do there's no way to sing
jobs nothing like this so I have nothing
against you well I retweet a girl that
selling videos or something like that
first of all I'm laughing because that's
what twitter has become yeah
for some women they're selling videos on
their the hot wok mom from Texas the one
that has two always sells the gangbangs
I show my wife and we house I can't
believe that they allow that on Twitter
I'll be sitting there I go honey look at
this tape and she's just getting dick
from eight different directions it's on
Twitter and so we'll be watching TV at
night I'll check my messages and I'll go
to Twitter to see what's on Twitter just
to see if anybody message me and
somebody you know wrote something right
and when I open up homepage she's always
on them getting [ __ ] it's the same old
video and she'll say I just sold three
more videos on hot bod to go to hot bod
xxx or something like that right well
it's live she's sucking a dick there's
one video she made well how [ __ ]
playing with a [ __ ] and follow the
electrician damn oh it's [ __ ]
craziness and then I'll take it I don't
understand there's a friend
like know who does porno and that's what
she told me she goes it's really weird
and this was she hasn't even do porn
anymore this was five years ago she goes
if I would put a clip up they would take
it off
but if red bands old girlfriends right
would put a clip on they would leave it
on it's really weird this selection if I
think if they get certified or because
the dog listened there's another girl
there and I became friends with online
do you remember the girl that i
retweeted and then she got pissed off at
me because i retweeted I thought it was
goofing on yeah and then she said that
she was getting threats but then she had
me back and she goes I saw like two on a
video yeah thank you
it's really weird if I see a girl
shaking her ass on Twitter I might give
her a retweet just there's one that's
really annoying I don't even know who
our name is she's got to go oh she's
just because she's like a washed-up
porno star she's washed up but like
everything she's lost everything like
Tabitha Stephens is still beautiful yeah
she's not washed up she's still [ __ ]
beautiful to happen to Stevens you know
i retweeted or the other day she'd say I
saw that everything yeah she looks
[ __ ] beautiful [ __ ] she was
throwing Heat she doesn't give a [ __ ]
but there's some of them that it's time
for them to go like that I didn't get
the memo yet like it's time to go nobody
wants and she's the worst one because
she makes a [ __ ] squirt so like you'd
be [ __ ] going on your homepage on
Twitter saying you see and she's got the
ugliest [ __ ] it squirts like crooked no
it looks like my dick like it's got like
a turtleneck so like when I piss I have
to pull the skin back and not the piss
of all we wear like a flap like if it's
a 50-50 that's where I always pick up
the toilet I've always done because if I
loose again down I could just pee on my
pants I get it everywhere no I never do
oh yeah you gotta pull the skin back
okay the image of your hand flapping
around sorry I know you're Jewish we
shouldn't be talking
yeah no idea anyway it's great to be
here on a [ __ ] Wednesday you're still
alive who's better than you [ __ ]
nobody eight weeks we've been under
[ __ ] acquisition killing people fake
numbers I don't even know them or who to
believe all I know is we got a great
guest for you to listen guys I love it
when I do a podcast with somebody and
you guys enjoy it and you guys feel a
certain chemistry because the better
friends you are with somebody the better
the podcast because the better the
stories the longevity they've got the
friendship David got and they warp they
have a lot of people want me to do the
podcast I don't know them it's just an
interview I sometimes I ain't
interviewing people it's just a
conversation this guest that I have on
today is one of my favorite people in
Los Angeles I gotta tell you he's one of
my best best best best friends he's
[ __ ] down his [ __ ] for me he was there
when my daughter was born with a camera
he showed up I went out to breakfast
we've been on the road together we've
been friends for 20 years and I love him
to death and I'm proud of him that what
he's done with this show midnight gospel
because it really is the mind of Duncan
Trussell and he [ __ ] put me in this
show like you know when the guys on cam
and Greg Garcia pour you up you feel
like on it so Duncan Trussell ladies and
gentlemen kick this [ __ ] to me Lee
[Music]
there he is hey [ __ ] universe
my little brother look at them which
[ __ ] clouds behind you liked it I
liked it I gotta get that effect you
know I'm saying oh yeah man it's all
about the green screen these days Joey
that's what we're at right now
how are you brother I'm great I don't
know man what about you good how's your
child oh man
beautiful just beautiful happy you know
my wife is just killing it you know
she's I'm just so in love with her man
watching her be with a baby it's the
most psychedelic beautiful thing that
ever happened to me and he's just great
you know he's you start he's like fine
he's done he did his first joke you know
at me which is you know he's obviously
he's learned the word boo-boo and my
feet are so [ __ ] up that his thing is
to like point at my feet and go boo boo
sixteen months how fun it's the next one
how much for that you know you wish
don't go to sleep at night you like that
no no like a night your wife's like all
right it's bedtime
you like mind your business there's
times where you want to go wake your
mind yeah I do I do I go in there's a
little night sometimes I got one and put
my head on his stomach and rubber on
you're in no danger waking had a little
[ __ ] up Cosby oh really
oh my daughter she sleeps like a Cosby
victim you understand me she goes deep
into the murky waters utterly underworld
I've even told I go you ever get up at
night come and go a little bit we'll do
some snacks
maybe we'll watch a movie is she looking
like really yeah wow that's he's nowhere
near that age man he's still at the age
where if I he if his sleep cycle gets
[ __ ] up you know he's grumpy the next
day you know he's still at that age
where like and he's in a crib still you
know what happens you gotta hit the crib
in it yeah what time does he go to bed
we come seven 6:30 or 7:00 and he sleeps
the whole night straight yeah did you
know most of the time yes nightmares
sometimes it scares the [ __ ] out of me
well he's your kid what do you expect
these guys you don't think there's some
leftover sperm
leftover acid and [ __ ]
hallucinogenics and that one nut when
you got a pregnant you know there's got
to be something wrong well my darling
bored you just looked around for a
little while oh my god no she caught 20
milligrams of an edible one day they
catch that [ __ ] they can and you'll see
them eat one day and all sudden you see
them going through it that's a that's a
little flashback from the womb you know
saying not to disrespect your mother my
mother but those [ __ ] smoked
cigarettes they drank Clorox in the 60s
and 70s moms didn't give a [ __ ] they
drank alcohol it was still all right for
them to drink alcohol on the fetus they
were out doing jumping jacks I didn't
give a [ __ ] now they're out running and
jogging and she said mine's dead [ __ ]
in the 60s used to smoke cigarettes my
much pregnant my okay my brother this is
one of the stories my dad like to tell
my so apparently my mom and my dad they
were using like a an 80 year old
pediatrician right like he was this old
southern pediatrician and so he died and
they took my brother when he's a little
little baby to a new pediatrician you
know you're just going through all this
stuff that you give to the baby and the
new pediatrician is like what the what
are you doing that the old pediatrician
had been giving my brother Laden them a
lot of them which is opium so like which
is an old-school like just like an
old-school medicine that they would give
kids when they were crying so like when
my you know brother was a little baby he
was getting like hardcore opium like the
kind you would drink back in the opium
dens in a hundred where's this doctor
we should look that [ __ ] up with
Roman and elope [ __ ] Laden them I'd
love that can you imagine a couple
[ __ ] smoked opium on a Friday night
you just sit there or you got like a
Chinese chick to play the violin for you
you have no idea those are the good old
days now we got a live legit now not
only do we have to live with jet you
have to live in the spotlight you have
come out with one of the most
mind-boggling animated I don't even know
what to call it
it's it's a hybrid animated you know ten
years from now people are gonna go be
watching this and midnight movie
theaters six long year olds are gonna
get high cuz the first I watched two
episodes I'm like this [ __ ] is out it's
too crazy I know what this means this
means mushroom maybe a [ __ ] shot of
heroin you need to do drugs before you
do midnight gospel all right before you
even get into it what you did was
totally a mind explosion I know you had
a partner on it yeah but I saw a lot of
the mind of Duncan Trussell the thing at
the end with moms you know you just hit
it out of the [ __ ] Park kid thank you
I mean it's but you hit out of the park
and you did a Roberto Clemente it was so
beautiful so and landed perfectly it
just hit at the right time when America
needed it
Netflix is never gonna tell you the
numbers but it exceeded millions because
people were home it came out and knew
and a great [ __ ] time and I know you
hooked me up you gave me a couple
[ __ ] voices that was tremendous yeah
first episode I'm yelling weed I watch
it with my daughter the first time for
about three minutes and you started
saying [ __ ] you just looked at mango
it's time for you to abandon ship I
think this is adult entertainment it's
not a get you
it's a it's a great show but not if your
mother for you you know if she was nine
I'm trying to create a savage yeah why
not yeah but I'm not trying to create a
savage [ __ ] Duncan I gotta tell you
something during this whole thing it's
just great to see you great see Joey I
miss you man I miss you too brother this
is [ __ ] up I mean it's [ __ ] up
it's I I want I wanted to talk to you I
wanted to ask you first of all thanks
for watching the show man and I didn't
hook you up you hook me up by being on
the show thank you for being on the show
you killed it
you know what's really cool about you
man is that you're not just a great
comic one of the great comics you're
also you work your ass off to be an
actor and so when you know you see you
working and for the first time getting
to see different people the way they
work in a vo booth you know and seeing
people who are trained everyone did a
great job but like seeing people like
you and Phil injury or trained actors
and watching you know all those years
and years and years of work come out in
the room and not just that but the way
you're like connecting with everyone in
the room you're like doing this thing
which is real really really cool to
watch that's I love watching I don't
care what it is man I love watching
people who are experts at stuff you know
what I mean whatever voice overs you
have to go into the room and connect
with everybody in that room if you want
this project to go well I have to let my
ego go and let the four guys who know
what they're doing
guide me you tell me you know I'm
directl
you tell me what yeah you tell me bang
my head on the wall that's a job I
accept it I bang my head off the wall to
get the visual that you need you know
he's so working with you guys was also a
[ __ ] pleasure because it seemed like
just going in and do what you need to do
do it this way do it that way do it this
way we have forgotten how to create
anymore the reason why I wanted to talk
to you today is because you created
something
hmm everything is so put together go
watch it like a movie that's three years
old that was big three years ago you
watch it now and you're like that was
put together the day this is this is
this is acting casting not with your
show I felt it I filmed the characters I
felt the richness the stabbing the guy
and he asked you know just you took so
much from the your world and put it into
this and I'm just listen man I cheered
for everybody but for this one I went
nuts
I applaud thanks man I turned my nieces
onto it cuz why one niece is a real nerd
and when I hit it with it because I've
seen the trail I can't wait for it to
come on ago your [ __ ] uncle joey's in
it go for my I sent her a picture of
black guy putting the Firecracker with
his eye and blowing it up how fun is he
just doing a couple lines of coke and
saying like every 10 minutes it's what
having a Chinese guy in Boogie Nights
just happened to him listen put a fire
cracking yeah I'll give you an extra
gram a blow and drive me to the hospital
don't worry why I get through with that
pool guy there'll be no eyes left in the
state Joey what do you thinks gonna
matter this is the thing that has been
dawning on me cuz I guess I'm slow as
[ __ ] but you know I've been thinking
like what's gonna happen to stand-up
comedy like what like you know the other
day I was talking to my booking agent
and you know like just getting a lowdown
on what's happening out there and the
whole industry is paralyzed right now
and you know I just was wondering what's
your take on it man you know you've been
hitting the road for so long like what
what what do you get what is out there
what signal are you getting out there my
situation is as follows and this is you
know everybody's situation and is
different than this you have a wife you
have a child you like creating
very comfortable creating different
things you've always done great this
isn't your first time at the rodeo you
have other shows that you sold before
and finally you found the one you know
you gotta kiss a couple frogs before you
meet a prince you know sanneh share
so for examining [ __ ] I'm just waiting
for Netflix to put it in the second
order for the second season I'm not
jinxing yet but there's any phrase if
they wouldn't so you've got another year
coming okay that's you myself I do
videos for you know different corporate
events and the podcast we're not getting
rich but we're afloat okay as far as the
road is concerned you know hey I don't
know who this [ __ ] foul a guy is and
I don't know who half these people out
there telling us what's going on I know
that I've had friends that have had it
and I had a kid that I went to high
school with died from it I want to give
him a Dave Phillips rest in peace I had
to beat him up one day because I thought
he robbed my house we were like 15
somebody robbed my house and they put
him on me and I caught him in a bowling
alley
hallway he couldn't get out I caught him
in the [ __ ] hallway and I apologized
to him later when I found out who robbed
my house yeah over the years we
connected and we were deer on Facebook
he's one of those sad stories that went
to the hospital and they sent him home
and then went back and died in the
hospital
goddamn so I don't know what's going on
with conspiracies I don't know if you
should wear a mask I don't know if you
should put Clorox in your veins I don't
know if he should I know I'll tell you
what kind of work for Joe Diaz I just
told you what's gonna work for Duncan
and I'm gonna tell you what's gonna work
for Joe Diaz Joe Diaz is probably gonna
do some type of residency at the Brahe
improv to Tuesday's a month maybe maybe
one way
they a month up a lot up in Oxnard and
I'm gonna continue to wear a mask
I'm gonna continue social distancing
times 10 no fan shots no nothing no
nothing basically no nothing I mean I
gotta know who you are where your
background is I have a system for comedy
you know you've been in a comedy club
but when you get there you nothing to
talk to minutes and there's 10 knocks on
your door with 10 people want to know
what song you want to go on what you
want to eat they want to introduce
themselves as a girl here and then
Melissa do you want know
yeah I'm cutting that down to one person
every club is gonna have a covert
advocate all right mask clubs pick us up
clean car I want to smell the Lysol and
this I'm just gonna fill out a feel
outdoor waters yes it's too crazy I pull
the plug I've been doing this for 30
years I got nothing to be embarrassed
about
I'd rather it's better to quit ahead
than quitting it's a big [ __ ]
difference yeah what about the I mean
just from financially if they're gonna
do like half if they're gonna fill the
room with half as many people I mean
that affects everything that affects the
club's overhead listen it's called the
cove in 19 but what it should be really
called is pay cut he had this is member
Paul Mooney you and I grew up on Paul in
the morning yeah and every once in a
while he'd look at this and say man you
got your [ __ ] wake-up call everybody
gets said [ __ ] wake-up call no matter
what color you are I'm not being racist
I'm just telling you the truth we just
got our [ __ ] wake-up call you know the
flights people are not traveling hotels
you know you want to do it you want to
do an interesting you want to write a
new series of midnight gospel or you got
dudes go to La Cienega and make a left
onto Melrose and drive down Melrose
that's a new season of midnight gospel
so I don't know I don't have a fortune
ball in front of me
1 I don't want none of my friends to get
hurt and number 2 I don't want anybody
who comes to my show to get that [ __ ]
right
so how guilty will I feel for 25 bucks
you came to see some fat [ __ ] felon
crack jokes and you got covered 19 Wow
for four days you know I love these
people that they real am out of the
hospital rooms and they're clapping and
they're like he's been here for 40 days
wait until that [ __ ] gets the
belt wait time get the belt especially
in New York wait till he gets the bill
so there's a lot of tumbling that's
gonna happen that we haven't even seen
yet you know we stay close to July 15th
what I'm gonna have that much comedy
left to do here in Los Angeles you know
there might be up in the rural areas
whatever but for the most part listen
you got your health yeah you've got your
child you got your little show that's a
[ __ ] tremendous show it's the mind of
Duncan Trussell and that's all we need
to worry about right now nobody I I
can't call you up and say Duncan I don't
know if I can make your birthday
December 9th this year how bad is that
we live in a society right now that I
don't know what November 8th is gonna be
like right I don't know if I could fly
home to see you Thanksgiving I don't
know if I could I don't know how are you
gonna feel when you step on a plane and
reality hits and all of a sudden you
Knight had told you the plan is 40% full
but you gotta act like a guy like me
sweating sitting in the middle seat poor
[ __ ] grinds on your shoulder how are
you gonna feel so yeah this is gonna
take a time to heal where were you at
right now is process of healing let's
talk about it because this is like
morning what happened was we said
goodbye to our old life you've already
mourned your dad you've mourned your mom
which you haven't even started to yet
within right but now we have a third
morning which is this
our old lives life what life used to be
like when I can see duncan give you a
hug and pick you up yeah now I gotta
[ __ ] do a straw a line or something
give it to you and light it on fire we
can't even use the same line you know
what how do you feel right now
post your old life you know man and you
know how that [ __ ] is it's I'm it's
hitting me in waves it's like where it
really started hitting me is when I
realized you know oh yeah the comedy
soar is you know I was thinking like
what are the reasons I stay in LA and
you know one of the one of the big
reasons with the Comedy Store I only
went up there Fridays and Saturdays but
that was everything I mean that was I
loved that you know or even just knowing
I could go up there or knowing if I
wanted to on any night I could drive
there and see friends and hang out and
just you know absorb the energy at the
place and so that is what's hitting me
the hardest man is I keep thinking of
Mitzi and I keep thinking of all those
names on the wall and I keep thinking of
all those years that you know different
people work to keep that place afloat
and all the times that it was gonna shut
down and I just keep thinking of how
expensive it is to have a place on
Sunset Boulevard and I just keep
thinking like damn I mean let's say they
do open up but you can only do half
capacity and you know I just keep you
know from me I just wonder what's gonna
happen to that place and then from there
you know I don't know if you've been
reading about this but all these like
you know staple clubs in LA or really
probably gonna shut down man they can't
stay open they've got no they got to pay
rent and they can't they've got no money
coming in so I keep thinking of like all
these places for me it's the Comedy
Store there's many other places like
that that are communities that are based
around a structure that you know is not
gonna but you know it's how long cannot
sustain itself so for me I keep thinking
of that then I keep thinking of like
[ __ ] is LA going to turn into
troit is the same thing that happened in
detroit can happen to LA which is you
know what's gonna probably happen in San
Francisco any place where people begin
to realize that the incredible price of
living there which was worth it for all
the great [ __ ] that you could do now
what do you got you you you're paying
all this money to live in the [ __ ]
place the business taxi er is insane and
you can't go do stand-up
what if the comedy source shuts down man
if and I mean I've haven't heard
anything about that I have no idea
hope it doesn't but if the Comedy Store
shuts down I you know and I can't see
you and in the flesh I don't understand
why I'm gonna stay in LA cuz you know if
we do get so lucky that we get to do a
second season we're definitely gonna be
telecommuting for that you know like
it's not like you're gonna bring
animators in to potentially risk getting
sick when they can all work from home
anyway so then you know that would be
the other reason to stay here in LA what
are people gonna go on commercial
auditions now [ __ ] no it's all gonna be
telecommuting for auditions anyway so I
just keep thinking the city itself is
going to you know it's I don't I don't
think people really quite realize how
[ __ ] it is here man I don't know I
haven't heard much on it but like
there's people paying 15 2000 dollars a
month for a four hundred five hundred
square foot studio apartment because
they wanted to break into combi or
whatever right now you can't do stand-up
you know these are the people who are
driving goobers and [ __ ] well what are
they doing what what about all the other
people are working here what about all
the we laid off 3500 people or 350
people yeah lyft has nothing so what I
can tell you is this I'm gonna drop some
pounds I'm still gonna be high risk this
is my age and blood pressure which I
have a pretty much under control excuse
me for that little protein shake bark
one for a little bike ride this morning
no problem
you know for me I gotta be honest with
you on my risk not as high risk as a lot
of other people have some muscular to me
I work out I still get a hard-on you
know I'm still halfway there I want them
to open up the businesses but right now
just a couple of them little by little
to see how people my whole thing is the
reaction of the people yeah
the reaction of the people will social
distancing work I will tell you as an
observant guy I'm always looking for
cops drug deals you know me I'm a [ __ ]
whackadoo that just uh it's it's it's
unnatural for us to social distance our
own being attracts us to other people by
mistake yeah every time I see you I
gotta take the [ __ ] ruler out you
know ya succeed whatever ten feet just
all that [ __ ] that that's not gonna work
the mask wearing a mask cuts your
chances down by 18 percent or whatever I
just what coming up last if we open up
with sporting events you know baseball
games that's when comedy comes back now
there's two trains authority at Duncan
you and I both know that the comedy
store opens in August and they open it
on it's 70% capacity in the main room
how long is that gonna last yeah you
know I mean Peters a businessman but
that's it I don't think a lot of comedy
clubs are gonna last this are gonna if
this goes to August or whatever even if
they open up next week you're opening up
a week before Labor Day you've been home
since March 15th nobody wants to hear
see some [ __ ] guy at night sitting
indoors all right while the people lo
financially the thing I
about all the time that the financial
wall in this country yeah we don't see
it cuz we hang out with people make
hundred grand a year 90 grand a year but
I talk to people on the phone every day
who makes 60 grand a year and then I
don't be going to concerts for a long
time all right you know a lot of people
aren't gonna be doing a lot of things
for a long time so I'm just really
focusing on my health right now yeah
focusing on writing not that I even say
Tommy Riley focusing on writing
I'm not even writing anomaly why am I
wasting that energy for write whatever
material we were working on throw it
away cuz you're gonna have a new mindset
after that this is gonna change you this
is gonna change all of us because it's
gonna make us think for the first time
how we haven't thought about in years I
have a lot of free time to think right
now
and some of it is good and some of it
was bad but soon enough we'll all become
good and they'll clear the way for
what's coming up in the next couple
months all right but I just don't want
you or any of my friends or anybody who
listens to this podcast tonight is Mark
may 15th correct tonight they can open
up places I hope that you're not going
to a club tonight right I hope that if
you buy a grammar Bo you stay home and
do it with one of your friends and try
them out first you know you gotta move
your immune systems and go to [ __ ]
club fresh go to a gay club with three
em you know three gay guys start talking
to them take your grandma blow lower
your [ __ ] resistance and see where
you're at you know right I don't see
young I'm gonna be honest the church
family and with you Duncan cuz I always
am the other night I usually go to the
weed store in the morning to keep the
percentages of germs down I do all my
errands early I had to go to Walgreens
this morning I was there they know one
all right so there cuz they spray that
mist that night yeah so I go in a more
to avoid that stuff what was I going
with the story well I went to the wheat
store the Friday night I was bored and
they've got these new pills oh but urban
trees called ultra these pills will [ __ ]
you up I ain't like eight of them when I
was a drowsy I was actually [ __ ] when
that drooling what's the other word when
you sleep slurring the first night I
took them I hate the whole can even my
wife was like what are you doing with
your life I was [ __ ] slurring so I've
been eating these pro tabs you know I
drink a [ __ ] quickies cuz I gave up
the edibles because the edibles were
backfiring on me they were taking me to
a dark place once I got away from the
dark place now I'm back with the edibles
you know it's [ __ ] Wednesday we gotta
get the party stuff already good
business Monday and Tuesday yeah with my
brother Duncan and but going back to
your question I expect I don't want to
do stand-up on the road for at least
nine months I will set up a residency
here work at a whole new hour I'm gonna
see what people's reaction are are
people still gonna want to come shake
your hand and touch it and hey excuse me
can we do a selfie right now listen
right now closely people if you listen
to this and this comes directly from me
Duncan and I'm sure I could speak for
Ari Shaffir when I say this take that
selfie stick and that cow selfie thought
and shove it up your mother's ass there
ain't no more selfies in comedy alright
you want to taste send this selfie do or
like what everybody else does send me a
twenty I'll sing your side shot of one
of them nuts accent and I autograph it
for you how's that you had the grandmom
for Thanksgiving yeah I got you man
that's cool yeah I think you know what
one thing I think that is gonna happen
is that which i think is gonna be
spectacular because you know it's easy
to get on the dark side of this [ __ ] but
you know it's like when I would
interview one of my favorite interviews
was with
this guy who worked at this place called
singularity University up in San
Francisco
it's Ray Kurzweil Peter Diamandis the
Google people just basically the techno
Illuminati or you know have this place I
don't know if it's still there up in San
Francisco where they're sort of trying
to figure out what the [ __ ] gonna
happen when computers you know wake up
and they so in its it's not just like a
philosophical exploration it's for it's
a business exploration because if you're
running a business you need to
understand what the technological
landscape is going to look like next
year two years from now three years from
now so you can begin to plan for that
and start actually inventing [ __ ] based
on technology that doesn't exist yet but
there is going to exist and so otherwise
you're way behind the curve and you're
[ __ ] and so when I went in there man
this was years ago they had just done a
seminar and they had all these grease
boards up that had [ __ ] written on them
I wish I'd taken pictures of it man
because they [ __ ] it was like a map
of the next goddamn ten years it all
these predictions they all came true and
I remember looking at them in those days
and thinking that's pretty weird
for example they were writing like what
are the dangers of this that what do we
have to worry about in the next you know
five years and one of the things they
wrote down was what happens in a society
where everyone's being surveilled where
everyone's being recorded where
everyone's being digitally tracked
whether they know it or not if in you
know five years hola changes and people
broke the law five years before the law
became a law but they're on video
breaking the [ __ ] law right now that
was loosely loosely they were predicting
me too which is that suddenly you know
what I mean they were predicting that
they were talking about what happens if
social changes happen very quickly and
people have you know records of doing
[ __ ] that becomes socially completely
impermissible what's going to happen
and you're looking at you we saw it we
saw happiness all these [ __ ] who are
like operating is like complete scum and
who were depending on people not being
able to connect and talk about it they
all got [ __ ] completely from that and
that wasn't the only thing that they
were talking about the other thing they
were talking about there was really
spooky joey is that as technology
becomes more amplified the ability for
radicals to cause damage in society is
going to exponentially increase meaning
that genome editing for example was
going to become increasingly less
expensive to get the equipment you need
to do genome editing so you could start
doing like CRISPR [ __ ] DNA [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] you know warehouse that you're
renting for $1,000 a month you could get
all the equipment you need it for maybe
a hundred thousand dollars as opposed to
millions and millions and millions of
dollars essentially what we're doing
with podcasting right now we've all
become our own TV stations we've all
become our own networks we've all and to
do that you know 20 years ago would have
cost you countless millions of dollars
so anyway man it was like a really
creepy thing cuz he's like eventually
it's going to be the any individual on
the planet is gonna get to the point
where they might be able to launch their
own satellite or shoot down satellites
you know so this was like a thing they
were talking about but that the the main
thing he said is the reason we any of
this [ __ ] is happening is because of
market pressure you know people want
faster phones and because you want
faster phones it's putting all this
money into studying like artificial
intelligence you know like you look on
Instagram and you can do that dumb ass
thing or you get the dog ears it just
tracks it to your head dude 10 years ago
that would have taken all day long if
you wanted to try to do that tracking
right now it does it instantaneously
right it's insane
we just take it for granted that's an AI
that's doing that by the way so what I
think the silver lining of this is is
that there is now an intense market
pressure to recreate the performance
stage in virtual reality I'm not saying
the sad way that
people are trying to do it now and you
know I had my hats off to flappers
whoever the [ __ ] trying to do stand-up
comedy shows on zoom' it's just not
going to work I don't think that's going
to necessarily work but I think that
we're gonna see the emergence of some
kind of technology that isn't [ __ ] that
it's gonna let people perform I don't
know if it's VR I don't know what it is
without having to worry about getting
kovat and also if they if we do get that
holy [ __ ] man that's like the best thing
that ever happened to stand-up comedy
like if you could recreate the original
room digitally and actually do it even
come close to it the reverb in the room
all that stuff can already be recorded
man I use software that can duplicate
famous sound stages like places where
the Beatles recorded and [ __ ] they go in
there and look at the geometry look at
the acoustic quality and they can
digitally replicate that so you can get
the reverb in the same place that you
know the white album was recorded or
whatever you thinking what a second this
is what I was thinking I'm thinking when
it comes to comedy this is white this is
an option not for guys like you and I
but for option for the Chappelle's the
Rogen's the birds I'm in contact with a
well-known manager to a music band one
of the best bands in the world we met by
mistake and walked three days a week and
you know
Live Nation because of the money and
everything they were talking of doing
the tour but virtual the whole tour
would be virtual so you sit in your
[ __ ] house and you watch this [ __ ]
concert whatever I like it but I don't
like it because I like energy from
people stand-up is 62% energy from
people yeah you know I want to see a
waitress slip and a glass break you know
so yeah this is what I'm thinking I'm
thinking a guy like me in a year and a
half
could do an improv and sell out the
weekend but the reason why I can't do
the theater is because they're gonna go
so backed up with the heavier-duty
comics yeah
so I'm also prepared this guy from this
band they're gonna use this service and
the service is basically what can you
put in the room Duncan 300 people put
the 300 in put the service in and allow
it to the whole state for that night
yeah so they have an 8 o'clock show on a
10 o'clock show they can either pay 1250
to watch it live or you know I don't
know 1250 to the next day if they missed
it you know yeah that might be an option
I mean they're talking about a thousand
things but the problem is we're going
into the unknown not knowing yeah that's
the biggest problem we have right now if
I can look you in the face and say guess
what this thing is gonna be over in
October then you and I could talk you
and I we know we could jerk off to
October 15th and then we're gonna start
making projects for this [ __ ] note
October 1st yeah they're not telling you
that now that's selling you it's gonna
come back with strong with the flu
different mutations and we're still
talking about maybe just missile in
China to death you know which is an
option also that people have no idea
could be because not everybody's happy
with China right now all right yes I'm
saying well I all it needs is three
[ __ ] Sam not happy with me I
bought you Duncan they gotta go that's
it we'll call our other three friends
and also that's [ __ ] in the year of
the [ __ ] firecracker yeah we don't
know what we're going in tell your child
is 16 months my child is seven she's
going back to school August 18th but
it's already proposed that she's not
gonna see a classroom till January
all right 2022 guys
that's right I do not feel comfortable
with that whatsoever I've gone from
being a comedian r-rated comedian with a
GED to an assistant principal gym
teacher entertainment arts director yeah
yeah you know interesting I love what
I'm doing but the child needs more yeah
right the child needs a
intercommunication yeah she [ __ ]
skypes with her buddies and she
facetimes with her kids but you need to
get thrown to the floor
and eat what it feels like to fall off
the tree ya know so I'm worried about a
lot of things I'm worried about those
things more than I don't give a [ __ ]
about stand-up when it comes back all
right I'll come back when it's ready you
know what Elton John's making a comeback
Yoko talked to Frankenstein's uncle here
bringing him back in 2002 you know this
just bought people time for me
this ball is time just bought it's time
to get naturally brain healthy again
yeah the last 10 years have been heavy
for people
you've got married you moved to New York
you lived in Pasadena you got married
you had a kid you sold the show and
what's the last time you sat and thought
for a minute when you were in high
school that's I before you left and
you're gonna look call me one day amen
we got picked up but I could do this in
Oregon and save 62 thousand a year in
taxes I wanted that I got a house with
an extra bedroom you're always welcome
with mercy you know what right now you
got with the percentages you look at
that these dense populations yeah me and
you right now Duncan
we should get money get Lee and just
invest in [ __ ] buying people out in
New York for dirt because they want to
get out of the buildings we can become
slum Lords and wait five years for those
buildings to come up and carve it to be
forgotten about by that time Arabs will
be [ __ ] in the ass but harmless
Tolu anyway what are you worried about
covert for you never saying so I mean
there's a lot of things we could be
doing but I mean I would like to hear
like you talked about the beginning dong
about things changing but you Duncan
just did a show with a lot of it based
on your podcast Joey you ten years ago
didn't have a cell phone now you have a
podcast you're doing videos like things
change like I think this is scary
because it's happening all once but
don't you think like like yeah like we
don't need to be in LA to shoot TV shows
anymore now we don't talk like we can do
well you could the shows are so bad we
can live without them wait and you can
compare there's three shows that you're
gonna watch out of 100 that I made the
studio should just shoot themselves and
put the podcasters on all day
we've days of my lives on General
Hospital for old people
now it's great but the price how do you
think the filming scene is gonna go back
you being an intelligent guy what if
tomorrow somebody offered Duncan
Trussell just like they did the guys
from what's that movie I did basketball
what's dog training Matt what well the
parking what are they the South Park
guys what if something tomorrow comes to
Eunice's Duncan just your your network I
want you to do a movie and I want us to
start shooting November 5th for a June
release how do you how do you look at
this movie now how do you look at extras
how do you look at serving food and
wardrobe and the people on this set you
know is he really necessary or is this
Union [ __ ] right you know testing
before I'm hearing things that if Duncan
shoots a movie in Atlanta and it's an 8
week show and I shoot week 3 and week 8
I can't go home in between weeks out to
stay in Atlanta your cost
[ __ ] you guys they don't want me to go
back to my family and come back and
bring it to you they talk about a lot of
crazy stuff
so I think animation is really gonna be
high until they figure all this stuff
out for sure man
I mean absolutely yeah that is debt
that's no question about it
animation is the future for a while and
I love that because I think animations I
love it's great a free up a lot of stuff
we shall love it man cuz you're really
good at doing voices yeah you know I
want to I don't know how to do voices I
know how to do my voice yeah use it to
mug be helping you eat you can like okay
like with Phil Hendry what was so crazy
working with him is you know cuz he's
been doing vo forever problem is forever
and the way he could dial in what you
wanted so you would start in this
Broadway kind of telling him sort of
what you're the character was and then
Technol technically he's technically a
genius he could just dial it in
you know until finally you like zoom in
on exactly the voice you were hoping for
and then it's like he can stay he stays
on that voice and it's like I'm in his
head as a menu of hundreds of different
voices and you just find the one that
like works for the character and then he
can dial that in perfectly you know
there isn't a lot of like fumbling or
searching for it or getting off track
with that voice it's incredible man and
within but with you what you were doing
with the same thing energetically you
know and what was cool you know that's
the thing Mitzi always said about comics
versus actors as comics play themselves
actors play other people and so like you
and Paulie when I was writing I was able
to write for your voice you know like I
already knew your voice and it was easy
to write right for you which is another
cool thing about animation man that's
awesome well I'm not talking about
movies or TV or anything like that I'm
talking about something even crazier
than that which is like this is where
I'm like I love what's happening dude
I'm talking about a global consciousness
happening right now I'm talking about an
economy that's no longer based on living
near where you work
man why are people [ __ ] talking about
this man that's what's gonna happen
we're talking it's no longer gonna be
you have to move your body to some
[ __ ] overcrowded super expensive
[ __ ] place
so you can toddle your body into some
[ __ ] office and sit there next to
people in a cubicle and only see them
when you're going to take a [ __ ] or get
coffee you know what I mean that's not
gonna happen so now that means that
businesses are gonna exist not based on
some like city they're gonna exist is
these weird global conglomerates where
workers from all over the planet have
equal access to getting that job they
don't have to move to the place anymore
and this is where [ __ ] gets weird man
which is like all these [ __ ] cities
that were essentially had like chained
people to the city because of the
archaic idea that you've got to be in a
building with people to make [ __ ] that
you're making with your mind these
cities are [ __ ] Joey it's not like
you're gonna be able to like buy
property somewhere why be in a city why
be a lot of people live like in the
outskirts of LA and every morning they
wake up and they drive to you know
wherever the [ __ ] studio city wherever
to work they drive two hours there two
hours back because they had to get their
body into the place to have these
[ __ ] meetings with people that
everybody knows could have happened
remotely but they had to do it because
it was a superstitious idea that work
was better if people get their bodies
together smell each other's [ __ ]
farts dude it was the weirdest when I
was and working on midnight gospel which
I love man I love being an office I
could tell when I went that both all
four times that you were really happy
they were happy that it was a different
vibe yeah hitman is badass before you
say something else it really surprised
me that you had gotten involved with
midnight gospel because years ago you
and I had a pretty intense conversation
about the project before or the project
that you had worked on before that yeah
if I'm throwing you under the bus I'm
sorry
now you know you said that it was a year
of your life
it sucked you dry like a vampire and
when you did the math they ended up
making you know 682 an hour or something
like yeah so I was very surprised what
drew you to this project well man that
was you know the reason that that thing
didn't this is why I think you know fail
you this is a cheesy thing you say is on
the back of every cereal box but you got
to fail you have to fail and you you
have to like you know fail in
collaboration like when I look back at
any project I work out work down with
people where I like my ego is getting
involved too much or where my ego wasn't
getting involved enough where there was
like power struggles and [ __ ] that can
happen and bad collaborations or where
the idea itself is too foggy and fuzzy
and you're just like being instinctual
and stuff like that man you know I think
that like it that conversation you had
with was with a way more bitter version
of me man and that's how I was
frustrated no you weren't better you
were honest you were not better at all
you were very honest and you said you
know at the end of the week I did the
math and I ended up making like yeah 8
bucks an hour and it was just a yeah
yeah you go I gotta change something up
which by the way man and this sounds
cheesy but if you're working on
something that you love
that's fine as long as you can eat yeah
but if it's like you're looking at like
what's coming out and realizing it's not
that good that's depressing man now
you're like just trying to make it thing
and this is why you're having made
midnight gospel it's like any time I'm
watching in the old days you know you
watch a movie that sucks for me I'd
watch a movie this sucks and I'd be like
what a piece of [ __ ] man why would they
even now I feel some compassion you know
like take cats right I haven't even seen
it but cats they dropped all this money
into cats and it bombed and all those
actors they were excited about being in
cats and the CGI didn't work you know
what I mean there's like there's just
think if they didn't show the cats but
holes which is weird somebody actually
redid pieces of cats where they put
their buttholes back in but anyway cuz
it was too high for realistic Joey it
was like you can't do realistic cats and
then blur their but it's like that's
part of a cat is it flashes his ass at
you sometimes and it's just anyway the
point is all those people nobody nobody
Bree did cats for the screen and wanted
it to suck like everyone had good
intentions there was a lot of people
working on it and somewhere in there -
[ __ ] started backfiring they weren't
paying the somebody wasn't getting paid
enough somebody was getting paid too
much
they were in too much of a hurry and at
the end of it you get just a rancid
embarrassment and I feel bad for those
people man but with midnight gospel you
know working with pen I just it was like
finding somebody I could collaborate
with who really understood me and I
understood him to some degree I
respected him as the better way to put
it and I really trusted his creative
impulse and uh his his intuition and so
suddenly what formerly had been a kind
of scary not very satisfying experience
just became like magic like I literally
felt like I was in Hogwarts or something
like it I felt like I was in some kind
of magical temple I can't describe it
any other way man I would walk in to tip
Mouse so [ __ ] high man just you know
tripping and like walk in there and see
all these animators bringing our
thoughts into real life and feeling that
energy in there and feeling like
everyone getting excited because they
all knew what they were making was
something weird and new and like it was
every day was joy man it was like
walking into a church or something for
me and I love that and I'm gonna miss it
if we do get to do a second season and
we work remotely but that being said you
know Joey I think that the future is
gonna look really weird in the sense
that it's not going to you're not gonna
people aren't going to be living in
cities because they have to be there to
work I'm gonna be living in Georgia
you're gonna be living in Oregon Rogen's
gonna be in [ __ ] Wyoming
people are gonna be scattered to the
winds and we're all gonna be gathering
together like this except right now the
way we're gathering together it's still
technologically not that great you know
what I mean we have the technology isn't
there yet but it's gonna be man and it's
gonna be like we're hanging out in real
life
that's gonna that's gonna come I
couldn't wait to get to bed last night
so I could wake up just to see you you
know yeah man same huh there's not too
many people in LA I will stab them
[ __ ] for you know likewise and I
think you me and Harvey had a little
clique of early on at the store you know
things happen over the year over the
years but not between you and I I think
you and Ari whatever banged heads for a
while but at the end were all brothers I
mean yeah and here we are 20 [ __ ]
years later yeah that was 20 years ago
we ran out of the store and then [ __ ] Oh
quit and you became the talent
coordinator and there was the most you
could see how uncomfortable you were
being the talent coordinator but you did
it you got to spend time with the queen
of mean the King of Comedy Mitzi sure I
mean this has just been listen even if
this coronavirus doesn't let us do
comedy for the last two years
I'm fault like I experienced things I
never thought would be possible I had
got inducted into the Comedy Store
that's the gambino of crime families I
wasn't associate for a year I went in
there three times and she passed me and
after that I did what the [ __ ] I wanted
I became the comic who I am today
yeah what are your thoughts on this that
20 years we were [ __ ] around you were
a kid when I almost killed that [ __ ]
toilet quest of yours
that's the cocaine would tell me that he
was gonna come and get me in the middle
well you know man this is there's no
such thing as time this is what I love
about the ROM das community that I'm
part of is they just they have these
really great hippie ideas which I really
like to think about which is that
there's something called what they call
it soul pods like the way dolphins swim
in pods like souls do the same thing
except instead of we swim together
through incarnations like our bodies are
the ocean that our souls swim through
and we've been doing this forever
so whenever we're like whenever like we
die or whenever like you know there's we
always come back and find each other and
we find each other in all these
different ways you know in this case it
was like through comedy but we've been
doing this way longer than that man
sometimes we're probably fishermen
sometimes they're probably in the
military who knows man sometimes were
doctors sometimes who knows we're a bums
sometimes we're like crazy people
sometimes where mental asylums sometimes
we're like Birds we're like flocks of
birds but we always come back which is
why we you know you always know -
because there's certain people you meet
and they're cool or whatever but what
you know they're you're never gonna see
him again if you talk to him you'll talk
to me on there
but there's certain people you meet and
it just is an instant you just you just
start up like you know knew them forever
even though you just met him that day
you know this is I love that idea that's
how I feel about you and Ari and Joe
that's how I feel about art group you
know red band oh my oh my friends like
that and the same thing happens in the
ROM das community - you just meet people
and it's like it's to say like you know
man there's people like re I won't talk
to him for a year sometimes I'm
fortunately six months but the moment we
start talking that's over we it's like
we never stop talking there isn't like
it doesn't feel like a year went by
she's like oh yeah we're just exactly
back here so that's I really do think
that that's what is what happens with us
is we just keep sort of finding each
other through lifetime after lifetime
after lifetime and each time we probably
hopefully are learning a little bit more
getting a little bit more you know
kinder to our
so a little bit more a little less
[ __ ] crazy and I think over the last
20 years we all that we watch that
happen over the last 20 years I can't
think of one of us worse you live with
Joe for a while I think about all the
time teen 98 or something like that
99 you were living with Joe and I mean I
still remember you and Red Bank getting
into an argument in San Jose a breakfast
embarrassing he threw the hat at you I
can't believe you didn't wait for me you
know like [ __ ] you you were laughing so
hard Joey I'll never forget your powers
because this is I love this [ __ ] some
begins with argument at breakfast it's
just we've seen each other grow and what
about the guy in Houston that was show
up at the jars filled with Vikings Oh
God that was bad Joey bad way to tell
these people how big those jaws whether
he would it was like you know
construction truck
they have like hammers and light bulbs
he would pull the curtain up and it was
just jars and yeah like it wasn't my
kitty percocet well he had everything
you know what he came to my last show in
Houston did he lock jars he didn't give
me a thing he shook my hand all right
and he goes thank you for talking about
me on a podcast I felt special because I
was the guy that was given to you it was
him he gained like 10 pounds
he says he's clean now he still feels
weed but I still think of just our
comedy growth you know all that time we
put in with Mitzi the roadwork you could
tell in Midnight gospel ah Thank You Man
you know man I'm sick and tired of
people thinking they could just ride
into this town with no knowledge of
nothing and create a masterpiece it
destroys me
if you come to town and one year you're
a good white guy then one year you do
calmly there for two years you're right
then for three years you
you're somebody some directors assistant
and one day you come to me what an idea
I'll listen to you because I'd know that
you were smart guy and you've taken
different pieces of everything that's
what you did and that's why midnight
gospel is such a hit and you're ahead
and Hank man I'm just happy to [ __ ]
see you I want to beat you down
I want to cry cuz I'm so proud of you I
saw you as a little guy i'ma still
torturing people at the store when you
were the the casting whatever the
coordinator huh the talent coordinator
the talent coordinator they used to tell
people how to give you a Vig if they
wanted to perform don't mention the name
we haven't gone one night you wanna
screw spots he's gonna give me money
nobody talks to Duncan direct you talk
to me and I bring Duncan the money okay
nobody breaks the chain and I still
remember Duncan coming down like I
didn't know Duncan was dead ten o'clock
at night I got the guy in the corner and
I'm reading the rules listen they give
you 15 I want all 15 everything how am I
gonna live that's your problem that's
your problem five of that goes to me the
other ten goes to Duncan you and Duncan
don't need to he's like well I'll talk
to Duncan he's not gonna leave talk
about anything I'll smack in the face
never forget that you came out and I go
Duncan I'm talking to this guy and I'm
straighten him out I just walked up to
you and he was just left and I told you
do you remember what a person was no no
no and I remember you walked away near
like what's going on I'm like I got this
kid believing he's got to give us his
$15 to get on stage and we were just
dying about it we man we did it was for
one you don't realize and you can't
maybe you do but like you're terrifying
man like if you're new at The Comedy
Store and you don't know I don't know
you you know you're like Joey Diaz you
you know you have serious clout you're
[ __ ] hilarious
and also there's like you know I they're
the artistic hierarchy there
a meritocracy at the Comi store which I
always loved about it it was always that
it was like great if you have a show or
something like that but what really
mattered is how if you're funny or not
and I love that about that place in
general a structure forms around that
which I always liked I liked that you
know I I came up with a hard Krishnas
and that was they were really into this
concept of what's called the disciplic
succession which is that this idea that
like it's it's you know a kind of light
gets passed down through the generations
that from one from a teacher to a
student and and you know it's a very
sweet thing if you're lucky enough to
get that transmission and then you have
it inside of you it's not like something
in your head it's in your heart and so
like you know the Comedy Store had that
quality to it which is like people like
you had that light you know and then
like if people like me could sense that
and wanted it to some degree you know
and then there was a lot of respect
involved in there not like kissing
respect but just a lot of respecting
just what you're saying which is like
you don't just walk into the [ __ ]
Comedy Store and it works out for you
like I don't give a [ __ ] who you were
when I first got there man I literally
thought I was one of the funniest people
like I can remember like meet like Jeff
Richards sitting in a car with them and
he's just making me laugh but for me I'd
never encountered someone who trained
themselves and the ability to make
people laugh I don't always been
accidental
you know and so I just remember like
suddenly realizing like holy [ __ ] man
this you're you are a tiny fish very
very big pond deer man just because you
were making people laugh on the [ __ ]
School Bus
doesn't mean anything you know and and I
had to deal with all that pride I had
stupid hubris to man cuz I had you know
like I'd used making people laugh as a
tool I assumed it was like oh it must
have been at the top of my game I did
prank calls in college surely I've got
to be one of the funniest people ever
then you run into someone like you you
know what I mean who's on stage like
killing but you don't even count you
realize stand-up comedy wasn't what you
thought it was anyway you realized that
even the idea you had of what comedy was
was wrong and then suddenly you're he's
seeing whatever the [ __ ] that
which I still don't think they call it
killing now I think that's the wrong
word for it I don't know what it is
there's a there's probably better words
out there but you know what I'm talking
about man when someone's a word is
communicating at a high level yeah yeah
that's a good word for it because um
making you forget about everything
that's going on and I'm making you hold
on to your stomach but most importantly
I'm making you laugh against something
you believe it because I believe I told
Lee to become a really good comic
sometimes you have to talk about [ __ ]
that it's truly against you that's what
even makes it funnier that you don't
believe in it like you know you have to
believe it I'm confusing myself that
joint was pretty strong but yeah when
I'm on stage I gotta make the guy I
gotta make him laugh make him forget
about his problems and make them forget
whether they have politically correct
enough let them catch themselves
laughing and going all this [ __ ]
got me I better stop playing that
politically incorrect game it's like
when you play the South the Bible Belt
states for me ten years ago 15 years ago
I would come out of the box strong but
after eight I would make them remember
themselves that they were Christians and
my show went south now I go up to I
don't give a [ __ ] of your Christian
Right we're gonna talk about how to [ __ ]
from behind and he that has deep with
the [ __ ] cross around your neck and
now you got him laughing at what Dave
you know it's just it's just a weird
gift and I'm always grateful especially
when I live across from you knowing that
part of midnight gospel a little little
bit a little little little bit of it
came from all those nights being in the
original room and going up there with
[ __ ] Momo and playing I wish you were
here that's how that
mine started I never thanked B in the
back of the original room on a Sunday
night I'm hosting and I bring you up and
you got [ __ ] Momo and wish you were
here and he's talking to you and this is
a completely different mind you can't
believe that you were committed to this
character and that haven't made it
[ __ ] kill on Sunday nights yeah then
I went on the road with Rogen and we
would go to San Francisco in San Jose
and you would do a little Momo and I
would tell you you but I hide that
[ __ ] because I'm gonna break into
your room and kill them in the middle of
the night [ __ ] hey but Joey here's the
other thing that I got from the store
man that it helped me with is the
animation industry is like the Comedy
Store and titmouse is like the Comedy
Store it's homegrown animators there
it's and like in the same way that
comics are like out are Outsiders you
know you run into a real comic it's
always an outsider it's somebody who is
just completely unique the animators are
like that too like some of our
storyboard artists like one of them who
I love his name's Lord spew Lord spew
one of the he is you know so [ __ ]
funny but like I was able being around
them to recognize that I was really
lucky to be working with him because
Pendleton took me under his wing and
like he's like you know really respected
in that industry but I wouldn't have
known that I would have had the humility
to like let myself be in that place but
having been at The Comedy Store and
recognizing oh [ __ ] this is like the
Comedy Store and even though these
people aren't comics they have developed
this craft of writing through and making
people laugh through storyboards in the
same [ __ ] way comics have learned how
to make people laugh telling jokes and
that you know and I remember this kid
we got an argument and there was a thing
I didn't think was funny that he did and
I remember like you know you getting
these arguments in front of lots of
people man like you can't there's no way
to do it in a vacuum right and it's
uncomfortable because like I'm sitting
there and my ego wants [ __ ] to go one
way and I am thinking like damn I I've
been in the Comedy Store
I know and shit's funny I don't think
this is gonna work and then I start
realizing that's my eco like I don't
think I'm right I think I'm totally
[ __ ] wrong here which is the other
thing you learn at the Comedy Store you
learn to know when your joke ain't
workin you learn to know when your it
isn't and how to adjust and I remember
like that's what me and that guy became
friends is because I you know I listened
to him I thought about it I'm like
alright let's try it then we saw it it
was a tiny little moment in it but it
was funny as [ __ ] he was completely
right and so then in front of this whole
room of people who saw us getting this
argument they see this joke work that I
said wouldn't work and I had to say you
were totally right man I'm sorry I got
in an arm wrestling match with you over
that and then me and me and him became
friends and it was it wasn't just like
being on stage of the comedy store it
was working for [ __ ] Mitzi and having
to eat my [ __ ] ass man it was like
Bobby Lee coming up to my office and
pissing in a goddamn cup and leaving it
on my desk and walking out meaning like
I'd have to take that cup of piss you
know what I mean and like what are you
gonna do you know you either leave a cup
of piss on your desk or you have to pick
up Bobby Lee's piss and try to walk it
to a bathroom and pour it pour it out
without it getting on your hand you know
what I mean you you and I'm not
advocating that kind of like [ __ ]
fraternity [ __ ] hazing [ __ ] but let
me tell you you learn how to eat your
pride there a little bit man yes and
that in if you and in the right way that
can really help you collaborate with
people that can really help you like let
other people have a voice and because
you're not gonna be right all the time
you can't be mad and so good you know
that that that guy he did my podcast
recently and I brought that up at the
beginning of the podcast that moment and
he told me he's like man I really
thought you're gonna fire me like
because you know when you're working
with producers and [ __ ] sometimes their
ego gets in the way and they can your
[ __ ] ass you know but I but thank God
for the Comedy Store because I just
recognized him is for what he was which
is a brilliantly funny outsider so
anyway man I think that's the other
thing it gives us the Comedy Store is
like it teaches us how to work
now kids you're by yourself on stage but
the comedy sorts more than just being on
stage man it's like I'm on stage talking
with you getting inspired by comics you
know letting your soul fill up with that
energy and you know what I mean that's I
think that's another thing it gave me
relating to midnight gospel yeah I don't
know what happened I don't know how
we're gonna make it the next three
months you have your family I got mine
we got our house yeah we got a pen in
plenty of paper
we got an iPad and like I said I'm gonna
pick up something low locally so I can
working on every other week no pressure
I think even the pressure the store was
getting to me you know what man I'm oh
I'm a lot like you I'll tell you what
night I'll come down that morning I
don't know if I want to do stand-up on a
Tuesday morning but I was forcing myself
so this break for me has a silver lining
because it's letting me think about what
I really really wanted to do I really
want to be a little part of that little
girl's life yeah I really want to get
healthy so in 18 months when the soprano
movie comes out I have to travel the
tour you know get a couple dates out of
it see some people I dance doing
stand-up 29 [ __ ] years playing nine
years I've been going out at night now
at night I got a [ __ ] hooded
sweatshirt on a pair of [ __ ] shorts
I'm counting the minutes till I eat an
edible to make that hour less boring you
know yeah yeah they've cut my legs off
it's worse than communism for a guy like
me I could I control I'm Joel the
captain of my whole body if I say to
myself I'm not going to store for a
month
to take a breather I'd do it but
somebody else is telling me now and that
bothers me a little but I mean I'm not
mad at anybody it's a disease if people
are dying yeah so that's been a little
rough on me but doing these things with
you talking to you on the phone talking
to Hari
let's just know that we're still here
you know sometimes pain is good
doesn't let you know you're alive right
so I don't see you going through any
pain I'm not going through any pain I
just wanted to get together with you to
help some people that are having some
hard times and wanting to taint them and
open their eyes to the best show on
Netflix right now Thank You Joey
[ __ ] midnight gospel just and I have
friends that have watched it because
I've recommended the tool that I
recommended it to them cuz they're so
uptight they're [ __ ] you can't even
put a thermometer in there if there was
the seventies and they've returned and
said I like that I watch them with my
daughter so trust me Netflix got a lot
of views you did great and I just want
to let people know they got to see the
mind of Duncan Trussell Thank You Joey
and that's without the drugs we got next
thing is your mind with drugs
you're gonna saying hopefully by season
3 don't have a machine that you could do
high doses of mushrooms [ __ ] ketamine
and [ __ ] what they that Chinese [ __ ]
and then they put sensors on you and
whatever you see you could turn into a
movie and that's what I'm hoping for and
me you will Lika sit together do some
heavy duty number two from the Chinese
mixed right there we'll hand ya get
those fresh starts and when heroin is a
[ __ ] always get it I love you
let me gently Spotify iTunes YouTube
yeah have a great day thank you for
doing this I'll give you a call later I
love your brother Joe I love you man
thanks LEM your show
always
what you think of that [ __ ] I
love that I love talking to that dude
always an interesting time it's better
to have him in studio cos crazy as [ __ ]
happens when he's in studio but uh we
got him anyway
he's great if you haven't seen midnight
what the [ __ ] is gospel that joint was
good midnight gospel it's time you
watched all episodes I'm in a couple
episodes like I said he hooked me up and
that's it and that's that as dates are
concerned day none so don't ask I hope
you got your money back and once this
whole thing clears up we'll be back I'm
happy I could come on here today and uh
you know take your mind off your [ __ ]
for a [ __ ] hour I wish I could solve
this I wish I could make this go away
but I can't all we could do is giggle a
little bit tell a couple fucked-up jokes
and that's [ __ ] it you know I'm
saying I went yesterday I went against
myself the other day I'd take a ride
every day you know and every day you go
a different direction some days you go
deep that way and some lazy or that way
yeah they went that way
and Steve Simone our dear friend has
become a [ __ ] chef and yeah he drops
him off at the house what the [ __ ] he
dropped off meatball no he always
dropped something off and the other day
he said he went to this I'm not gonna
say the name of the place this Italian
place that sells like Italian supplies
here in Burbank and they got like olive
oil he told me what he was he bought he
bought olive oil and you put on the
pizza
he bought a special type of olive oil oh
he said he bought raviolis the same one
that his mother buys so I'm driving
towards that way and it's 11:30 which is
my cutoff time after 11:30 of you're at
listen I got new rule during the
quarantine okay here's the rules all
right
if you know how high by 12 go [ __ ] your
money by 12 you should be blasted you
understand me like blast I don't care
what you do I don't mean I don't care
what you do to get you there because if
not you're gonna get to good and I'm not
talking about ending up in a [ __ ]
rehab don't say that I ended up in a
rehab cuz show me talk Joey told me to
get blasted no no no no if you do heroin
just do a little skin pop something
straight that the leg you don't say
sit there watch TV like a [ __ ] if you
eat like eight vicodins a day cut it
down to two but pop like a half and I
get nine in the morning just to get the
window and pop with your breakfast and
if you're smoking dope you know listen I
wake up I wake up I have normal human
being I wake up i whatever I help my
wife with the cat's I drink my coffee I
try to write a journal as hard as it is
to focus right now and at some point I
know it's reefa time I go in the back I
don't know how long it takes like today
I got up at 6 I got so high today I
didn't even tweet that's how [ __ ]
high I got today because I had to go to
a [ __ ] MRI so I was so [ __ ] nervous
before the MRI cuz I don't like being
around people no more that's it like I
got it I got a I'm working myself up to
like four or five people you know like
you need to be talks and that's topsail
right now yeah like once I see five or
six people gathered like I get nervous
so against my best war girl you know
what let me help my wife out because
Robbie always are you gotta basically do
is boil water yeah and my wife makes the
[ __ ] sauce quick McGrew no meat no
Alec garlic you know whatever the [ __ ]
she puts in it hold the whole Tomatoes I
love it I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] so and
it just eases the burden off my wife you
know she could just throw that in there
you know he's a it's [ __ ] 21 meals my
wife is responsible for I [ __ ] hate
cooking
so I do I used to love to cook but then
I hate looking at wrongly that makes me
sick to my mommy no I don't like looking
at raw mean cutting [ __ ] and seeing
blood
chickens forget about wood when I was a
kid my mother would have a new Santeria
rituals and then you got to eat the
chicken they faked choking yourself it's
like you know so I like I don't like
cooking I just don't like it and when
you see a fat dude like looking I see a
chef he better be a fat [ __ ] I've always
said they show me a skinny chef but he
talks about kettlebells I want to do
business with you you shouldn't be
talking about kettlebells you should be
talking about calories and how to put
flavor and food brother you know [ __ ]
like that
that's why skinny chefs I stay away from
I see a chef for a night pack a six-pack
I don't want to do business with you so
rule number one during the quarantine
you got to be hind by 12 and rule number
two is do your shopping by 11:00 11:15
before all the [ __ ] morons come out
the earlier the better because there's
not less German in the store at night
they spray that [ __ ] woman juice into
the air that kills the bugs and all the
[ __ ] air so you don't want to go in
there at 6 o'clock because there's been
two other people in a supermarket so you
want to pick a small mark I go in there
early and I bet you beat the [ __ ]
rule hand generous before they [ __ ]
spread but I said [ __ ] I'm all the
way over here let me go into this place
at 5:30 and the 5:30 it wasn't no
[ __ ] fight they was at 11:30 and I
forgot it's a [ __ ] lunchtime crowd so
I went to the freezer I called Steve
Somalia what's the brand the ravioli
Steve Simone drops the brand on me I
grab a lobster ravioli a beef ravioli
thanks and I cheese ravioli just help my
wife out I got a loaf of bread you know
Italian bread just to try it out it was
[ __ ] they can't make it I took the bit
you know you get them on the drive home
you can't you can't hold yourself back
so you take the tip off yeah of course
like I think the tipper off Rene
tastes like a [ __ ] chameleon waffle
like I've got a church like a [ __ ]
had no flavor to it it's terrible so I
go in there and I get the bread like a
[ __ ] that I am cuz I'm high and I get
bread dot dot dot dot and I get to a
column I go I should help ground garlic
some cold cuts let me go back in then
get some cold cuts so I go back in on
some lady because you got to take a
number
so I said walk to take a number a
[ __ ] this [ __ ] half [ __ ] woman
is right there and me trying to be a
gentleman see it pays to be a [ __ ]
animal it used to pay to be a gentleman
no more because you give people breaks
and they [ __ ] all over you yeah this
lady tastes the [ __ ] number I say go
ahead
she takes it she gets in front of me and
after ordering like a thousand things
and sampling [ __ ] at the last minute she
throws in a [ __ ] gift card so they
gotta stop like to see your face at that
moment oh my god oh my god listen to me
I was 57 and the lady next to me was 58
she was dead only six feet from me and
I'm 57 and when she asking a gift card
the lady said no she didn't you from New
York she goes worst New Jersey I go
where she goes Cliffside Park I go you
ever go to Rudy she goes please I grew
up in that [ __ ] joint so we started
talking and I go can you believe the
balls and she does these white people
out here [ __ ] [ __ ] who are gonna
come at 5:30 and get a [ __ ] gift card
come here twelve to stop the whole
[ __ ] process the [ __ ] guy Julio
whatever Bruno you should have seen him
cuttin it was he was getting paid by the
[ __ ] century he would slice it like
you know his arm and I'll try this I get
to it [ __ ] suck you know I grew up in
a [ __ ] deli sliced that [ __ ] meat
and everybody else is walking around
like in 3d - they're like three Mexicans
nobody habla like they said the a B team
home and they have to be team to replace
see what's going
is they gave these Mexicans 100,000
thousand week for unemployment so they
were getting six legit so now they're
like [ __ ] what I'm going back to go with
taking our 11 weeks going back hell yeah
we're not cooking with the hey've so the
B team and they don't know what they're
not even maxing you I don't know what
they would they were like [ __ ] they
were like lost in there
they were like lost in there so damn it
on me
for going against my own rules don't go
against your rules
that's my I love especially when we're
out on like a show and someone asks you
to do something good what do you please
do a video for my just anything that I
know you don't want to do I just love
watching your face and why because you
say you you crack people you crack
sometimes - it's pretty funny like when
you can trying to be nice and polite
ly I gotta be honest I crack every day
every day I find especially the last two
weeks I crack every day at some point
from natural stupidity or something but
I keep it control I'm okay yeah you've
been under control I'm good I'm healthy
you know knock on wood they called up to
switch my physical I can't wait to get
the finger in the ass oh that's that cuz
now I'm gonna get the finger in the ass
and then you're gonna drive me again to
put the camera on my [ __ ] I'm do
without so six years ago I do it now you
can't do it why what do you mean not the
finger are you a professional what's
wrong with you you're [ __ ] in the air
so you know let's take a finger up my
ass
you probably ain't just the main one
like everybody else you [ __ ] just one
plus the one in your IPO what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me old you got that one of
my you did you would you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I love you see them saying I'll
deal with people you think it's an easy
day you're gonna just smoke a joint go
home I got a deal with this Dunkin trust
was great so watch midnight gospel I had
a great time on it and I'll tell you
what and it's the truth
act like the first [ __ ] five minutes
I'm like you got to get hard to watch
this yeah you got to do a head of
something you got to eat a mushroom wing
you got to do a methylene they do some I
call Josh Wolfram got the [ __ ] Joshua
I don't know where he gets his mushrooms
from that's why he's so skinny
he eats these [ __ ] mushrooms and he
goes to different planets M&R he get the
[ __ ] best mushrooms of all time I'm
not a mushroom guy gives me diarrhea but
for midnight gospel I had experiment I
had to take the chance Columbus did and
it was okay I enjoyed myself I had a
good time so if you get a chance watch
it follow his podcast and that's it and
that's that I don't know nothing about
dates I don't want no dates
I want able to be healthy everybody to
get financially settled and then we'll
talk about [ __ ] dates all right
everybody's taking a [ __ ] pay cut so
[ __ ] you you know I'm saying everybody's
taking a pay cut everybody's hurt and
everybody's going through the same thing
and I'm [ __ ] sympathizing Roy you
[ __ ] so thank you for listening
but before we let you go let me talk to
you about something seriously if you
listen to a podcast or you followed me
for years
guys like bobbling is who he spooky they
know I love me and these I love I wear
them I love them for working out the
whole thing me undies me on these me
undies I know you've been hearing this
from anybody podcast you listen to it
but here's the thing me and these is the
world's softest and most comfortable
sustainable Underpants in the [ __ ]
world alright it's like having an angel
it's like somebody having a little
baby's hand cradle you're nuts
I don't want don't say you heard it from
me they design their underwear for
comfort and self-expression point is
it's time you cut off your toxic
relationship with your tattle all of
these guys I know you're hoarding some
[ __ ] works of art in your [ __ ] top
drawer it's time to make an adult
decision and get rid of that [ __ ] you
show up at some girls
we're white underwear a little yellow
spot in front with a little priest tail
like a [ __ ] filthy animal listen
you'll never settle for a pair those
pieces of [ __ ] again alright you get me
on these delivered straight to your door
with free shipping they come in
different colors every month they send
you a different pair they are [ __ ]
tremendous you know I don't [ __ ]
throw no [ __ ] at you people these
are the most comfortable underwear you
I'm gonna [ __ ] have on period alright
they just don't make undies they got
loungewear and all the same fun patterns
that you love and Underpants every month
they send me and my wife the same
underwear not that were two [ __ ]
morons and we put them on together jump
up and down but my wife wears them to go
to yoga she loves a lot of that [ __ ] so
listen it don't stop with just men me
undies has a great offer for a church
family and the first time purchases you
get 15% off and free shipping you can't
beat it it's a no [ __ ] brainer
especially because they got a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee so do me
a favor get your 15 percent off your
first pair free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee go to me
undies dot-com slash Joey
Jay Oh II it's a no [ __ ] brain I'm
telling you right now with the
satisfaction guarantee
get yours today me undies comm slash
Joey I have a great [ __ ] weekend
thank you for listening thank you for
having our back and thank you for
supporting us and if you're going
through a hard time my heart goes out to
you and your family but guess what what
am I gonna come back mother [ __ ] this
everybody's gonna suck our dick the
Chinese the [ __ ] the Cubans so
everybody's gonna suck our dick don't
worry about nothing I love you guys
enjoy have a great weekend see you
Monday morning tip top Magoo no [ __ ]
stories do you think [ __ ]
[Music]